ce n est qu une famille à la fois ses
employés du haut commissariat aux
réfugiés des nations unies à contacter
les réfugiés syriens qu'ils ont
l'intention de soumettre aux autorités
canadiennes pour être relocalisés au
canada quand je cours je suis en train
de chercher des familles complet des
familles avec des jeunes arbitres et
socio économique est aussi un
pourcentage de cas médicaux pour remplir
cette mission ambitieuse dans les délais
il leur faut attendre la fin des heures
régulières de travail tous ici le font
bénévolement
ici on a la chance de vraiment parler de
quelque chose très positive très
optimiste avec les réfugiés alors on a
beaucoup de bénévoles c'est le début
d'une série de rencontres d'entrevues de
tests avant de pouvoir obtenir le visa
de voyage vers une nouvelle vie la
première de ces étapes celle entrevue
avec le hcr pour entre autres choses
vérifier l'identité de la personne à
l'aide de données biométriques
ces quelques centaines de réfugiés ont
franchi cette épreuve initial ils se
retrouvent tous de bon matin pour
attendre en famille d'être mené vers la
suivante partagé entre la joie et
l'appréhension
quand nous avons reçu l'avis nous étions
sous le choc
nous attendions la merci de dieu et la
voilà notre seule préoccupation c'est un
avenir sécuritaire et l'éducation de nos
enfants c'est le plus important
pour moi aussi ce sont les enfants
nous avons quitté la syrie pour eux
c'est leur avenir qui compte bien sûr
que j'ai peur
n'importe qui aurait peur et se demander
ce qui va arriver là bas mais je m'en
remets à dieu et dans l'immédiat ce sont
les centaines d'agents de citoyenneté et
immigration canada et militaires
déployés en jordanie au liban et en
turquie qui possède la clé de leur
destinée
dans ce centre des opérations ouvert en
grande pompe il ya six jours à amman on
reçoit jusqu'à 500 réfugiés syriens
chaque jour pour vérifier la composition
familiale que tous les documents sont
corrects on veut savoir c'est au des
amis ou de la famille de la parenté au
canada
aussi à vérifier leur poser question au
niveau sécurité et
depuis son ouverture le centre a traité
2000 dossiers ce sont deux mille
enregistrements avec questionnaire est
autant d'entrevue examens médicaux et
enquêtes sécuritaire mais jusqu'ici
aucun des réfugiés théoriquement accepté
n'a reçu le temps espéré visa pour le
canada on venait à peine de commencer
pas de visas qui ont été mis puisqu'on
prend pas de propos de risques pour la
sécurité et la santé des canadiens
on peut prendre
le temps qu'il faut pour faire un
filtrage du reader qui est sûr et aussi
s'assurer que les réfugiés sont en santé
et identifier leurs besoins
toute la logistique des vols sera prise
en charge par l'organisation
internationale pour les migrations
une agence de l'onu ailleurs on tarde à
leur donner le signal de départ
ils se disent néanmoins en mesure de
rencontrer l'objectif établi par le
gouvernement d'accueillir au canada dix
mille réfugiés avant le 1er janvier les
vols nolisés vont partir en rafale
plusieurs à la fois nous avons
probablement la capacité de faire deux
vols par jour de la jordanie avec
environ 350 personnes à bord on parle
donc de 700 personnes par jour 4000 par
semaine des vingt-cinq mille réfugiés
que compte accepter le canada environ
10000 pourrait venir de la jordanie pour
karen meeting de l'onu elle-même
canadienne il s'agit d'un geste de
solidarité sans précédent en ce qui
concerne la crise en syrie ce que le
canada est en train de faire c'est
historique
ici un jour dany on a plus de 630 mille
réfugiés syriens qui sont enregistrés à
vacoas alors dix mille réfugiés c'est
une proportion assez petit
mais quand même si on avait plus de pays
qui faisait un peu comme le canada qui
suivait le modèle canadien
là ça pourrait faire une différence même
si pour beaucoup le déracinement forcé
de la syrie provoque encore des soupirs
douloureux c'est pour faire une
différence dans la vie de leur enfant
que tous ces parents veut s'établir au
canada canadien de valence ici